hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
veronica six-toes
I'm Smith Asha fells we're gonna watch
the trailer today huh for minions
minions is a movie up not prequel I
don't know something about spin-off of
the Despicable Me minions I am Groot
that's my guru impression that group but
the flexing today group I am Groot is
guardians again as far as I know that it
means got a ride at Universal BAM I know
what I'm talking about because I listed
a few facts my minions minions minions
of beam over here they go by many names
Dave deserve the most despicable master
around
finding a master is easy moving a master
that's where things got freaky but
nonetheless they kept on looking
they became nameless and depressed
if this went on longer they would surely
perish then one minion stepped forward
Kevin felt pride he was going to be the
one to find his tribe the biggest
baddest villain to self Stuart felt
hungry mostly he was going to be the one
to eat this banana this frightened of
the chair
Wow awesome oh my goodness what I heard
they were doing a prequel I was like
what so big guys do a movie about them
and it looks fantastic
oh man it looks so funny
can I just get that in there yeah I
think it's a yeah say it again it looks
really funny we think it's funny mm-hmm
we think it's funny Samantha we think
it's frickin hilarious funny so that's a
couple things it's a couple's thank you
bye anything's fun good you find it
funny I find it funny if you want to
find someone you define things funny
I do like how it's really establishing
upfront that this'll is what led into
GRU haha that sounded funny it sounded
perverted that's what made it funny I
think you're the only one that led into
group the BG before GRU was hysterical
having this safe place before GRU is
pretty cool because this is pretty much
saying like you might actually see grew
by the end of this film and that's
pretty cool to see like oh this is how
the minions came to be angry because I
always wonder the [ __ ] they work how
where do they come from they're the best
minions ever I mean but they're a whole
species they're not be the best minions
that's the point they keep murdering
their mesh I love their language and
when they're on the boat they look so
karen licking each other and then it was
like sucking on his head
and it was like it was just so cute well
if you like all the ratings then our
relationships gonna get zinging to the
next level minions
we should have minions one day I want
minions they are so fun you know you
could be a single parent with minions I
could see you doing that one day I would
do it I don't need a man I'm an
independent woman no I could totally see
wait you like men I could have sworn Shh
we're nuts let's talk about this I
actually love the minions I'm in love
with the minion huh they're so darn cute
I really like him I mean I wasn't a huge
fan of just
couple me one number two was pretty cool
I liked it was I thought it was a lot
funnier than the first one but this I
mean the minions were the best part of
the movie in my opinion so in your
opinion the minions yeah was the best
part yeah as if she said this is Mason
at first I was kind of like wow they're
really accidentally killing a lot of
people in this yeah but then everyone's
like I kind of like the dark you it is a
great dark humor in a cartoon it's so
fun this is exciting this is exciting
anyway guys if can you do the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
where it's just it's a YouTube channel
should feel like it's you subscribed
veronica has a channel too I do there's
a lot of vlogging and music you should
check that [ __ ] out she's pretty awesome
longtime features the rage axe rejects
are in there primarily me the awesome
Ryan right he just won't leave me alone
he's just like attached my hips you know
you can't get a restraining order for
stuff like that
oh just mean we have things to restrain
ourselves you know what I mean
sometimes you really know how to make
people uncomfortable this is everybody
though alright yeah laughing as I came
up with like 14 jokes in a row just I
was like and give their all money
sometimes moments are more enjoyed to
yourself you know one of their tears so
oh yeah I do that every kid's movie
there has to be some type of
conversation about it helping kids um as
a gentle - just created it videos gonna
start going up next week so keep a
lookout for that subscribe in the
meantime you know how it works
come on you know how we do you know how
we do how we do it this is how we do it
this is how we do it I am normally
justice tourism I can't even hey right I
would like a shout-out okay right mr.
right last names also it's all
differently let's see Q what the [ __ ]
Samantha I'm just stating the obvious do
you just have to point out that it
spelled a little different so what does
it W before and something you pronounce
were right you really wanted it you you
really didn't Samantha if she's on my
side then yeah he's pissed
oh hey okay
who do you think's right in this
situation okay right and brother so we
just did brought it around I think we
should move on from this bit Thunder
works you bet it does I don't know hey
okay I'm calling in something love here
Samantha looks like a dream I don't want
a shout-out I just want more videos with
Samantha we had no idea this comment was
coming we had no idea oh my god oh my
god we're in love with her too we're in
love with her too even trying to get her
involved with this for the longest time
wasn't she yeah oh dude Samantha I'm
tell you that the three of us would be
perfect
she thinks so I think so come on done
just done oh wow love is like thunder
and it works I didn't think she was
gonna go along with it now I'm blushing
good okay but thunder works thank you
you're sweet
Gary Stallings I love dust till dawn can
I get a badass [ __ ] super shout out
PS where did you get your hat
I got my hat from Target and [ __ ] Jane
I was there I so remember that we
weren't together it oh why do we have to
talk about pastimes like that if the
three of us are gonna be together we
cannot talk about the past like that
yeah he doesn't like
talking about you know stuff past two
months ago all right Gary Stallings I'm
gonna give you a badass shoutout what's
what's badass to that kid - what's that
huh come on come on come on what's oh
your freestyle for you okay how do we do
this uh new background beatbox away she
wants to be bucks barely you do
background world hot enough Gary
Stallings you got me bawling you got me
wanna make another phone calling I be
hollering at Gary Stallings I tell him I
love just hold on here we go gonna talk
all night long wanna do this
I'm Ryan Wright they're never wrong you
a badass [ __ ] here we go here we
go I'm it laughs like a Chris Tucker
Gary you like movies that are scary Gary
here you go your balls are hairy
Gary you want to do something well I
like you and I like Jim Carrey too much
of goods